you
[Applause]
please be seated
executive vice president Tolstoy faculty
colleagues alumni doctoral candidates
and their families and friends good
afternoon and welcome to convocation for
PG candidates in the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences at Columbia University
I thank you all for coming to celebrate
the many accomplishments of our doctoral
candidates we honor today a magnificent
group that on commencement this coming
Wednesday will receive the highest
academic degree in the land let that
sink in who will join the ranks of our
close to 40,000 alumni and who will
embark on professional and academic
careers around the world in the great
tradition of Columbia University our
candidates will always remember this day
even with the passing of the years they
will manage to recall that their
Columbia PhD convocation took place on
the very day in which the faith of
daenerys targaryen and the Iron Throne
were fulfilled
but I digress
equally important we also honor today
the families and friends of our
candidates who have endured with them
the long rigors of their academic
pursuit thank you for being so
supportive and understanding and above
all so very patient I would ask all PhD
candidates to rise and applaud those
friends and family members friends and
family members who have also helped them
to be here today please
the student remarks to the graduating
class will be offered by Jason Wang
Jason Jason Wang graduate graduate summa
laude with a BS in environmental
science and policy and a BA in Germanic
studies from the University of Maryland
and is a PhD candidate in sustainable
development his his dissertation
combines economics policy and science to
study how aviation connectivity
stimulates innovation and how climate
change impacts critical infrastructures
Jason grew up in Hong Kong and Shanghai
with family roots in Maryland he has a
long he has long been a dedicated
teacher he was on this stage two years
ago when he won the 2017 presidential
Award for outstanding teaching by
graduate students after being a two-time
finalist in 2015 and 2016
Jason's research has been recognized
with an award from the Transportation
Research Board of the National Academies
of Sciences engineering and medicine
his passion for international diplomacy
policy and language led him to become
last year one of the eight international
parliamentary fellows representing the
United States at the German parliament
mister Wong
[Applause]
this is a lot scarier than before
Dean Alonzo an executive vice president
chose story faculty and staff
dear family friends and of course the
PhD class of 2019 I'm a static and
honored to be able to deliver it a
student speech here today first of all I
would like to thank my advisor Scott
Barrett as well as my committee members
Jeffrey Hill John mater Jackie Club and
Radley Horton and so many other faculty
and staff members here who have advised
and mentored me over the years and of
course my family and friends who are in
the audience today having defended my
dissertation on aviation and sustainable
development I can now read for a
pleasure again right now I'm reading a
book written by a pilot named Mark van
Honecker so I didn't go very far from my
field and in this book mark chronicles
his journey in pursuing his passion for
flying and the unique views he gathers
from 30,000 feet today I'm here to talk
with you about one idea that resonated
with me and it is the idea of a place
Lag so what is a place lack you might
ask well I'm sure you're all familiar
with the idea of a jet lag after a long
transoceanic flight you're probably
really tired because the time zone
changes cause a sense of this
orientation jet lag by and large is
temporal place lag on the other hand is
spatial it is the displacement of place
rather than time that causes the sense
of disorientation a place lack can
persist even after you have corrected
for the jet lag
we have felt place lags everywhere in
our new beds on campus at that new cafe
that is part of your
tnow and your new jogging route along
the Hudson and even a brand new language
spoken around you these are all physical
dimensions of a place lag that we have
experienced one way or another as a
graduate student sure enough these kinds
of lags took time to get used to but we
nonetheless adjusted and yes we
experience plays lags all over again
when we go travel to a conference or we
go out and do fieldwork New York City
and Columbia became our new home base at
some point we began to measure and
compare places with a new baseline we
use Central Park for size we use time
with LaGuardia how long it takes to get
there and the prices of subconcious
sandwiches became our new currency units
we also feel place lags as firmly as are
very familiar places to us more than to
the new what used to be Ollie's at the
corner of 116 and Broadway has now
become Shake Shack like many
establishments that have come and gone
but to those of us who began our time
here at Columbia some years ago I'm not
gonna say how many the geography of
Morningside Heights and indeed our sense
of place will always be anchored by our
first impressions when we first arrived
on this campus and then one day we
realize this discomfort that we feel
spends more than just the change and
physical place our academic or
professional place also suffered a
significant lag once upon a time we were
the best in our subjects all of a sudden
we became Impostors everyone's pedigree
makes us question whether we were the
accidental admit maybe you struggled
with your first-year coursework like me
or dreaded through the comprehensive
exams or the master thesis before we
knew it the next phase of this kind of
place lag hits us in full force are we
considered successful if we don't end up
with a shiny
academic placement out there on the job
market thankfully we had a community
here who helped us cope with the
academic place lag I'm really grateful
to my program and my program comrades
who offered me their patience and
intellectual unpacking of some of these
feelings mental health is a central
component of graduate school education
let us not hide it as a taboo as it has
been too often the case and take a
moment to celebrate those of us who are
newly learning how to seek help when we
need it as well as those who have found
ways to train and learn more about our
minds unmentioned so far though is one
other dimension of a place lag that I
want to talk about this is beyond the
physical or the academic this is a more
abstract more identity base kind of
place lag it is the kind of
disorientation or discomfort as a result
of being out of place cognitively or
socially in your surroundings it is the
feeling of you don't belong not because
you're changing your physical places or
because of your academic or professional
places being changed it is because we
have no choice but to continuously
confront assumptions other made for us
or we have made for ourselves sometimes
these kinds of questions and comments
you encounter can come from very
benevolent places have you ever been
asked the question where are you from
followed almost immediately by the
answer no no no I mean where are you
really from apparently I just got the
wrong answer for others your place lag
may have roots in racism sexism
xenophobia other forms of unconscious
biases those of us here who command a
different accent who come from
international or different migration and
background
who are of racial minorities who are of
a different sexual orientation or gender
identity have you ever been told that
you did something really well for your
sex or gender have you ever been told
that you have to have a discussion
before you decide where or when you can
hold hands with your partner did you
have to try to muster a smile when a
complete stranger in the New York subway
utters the only Japanese words they know
to try to greet you have you been told
that you speak your mother tongue
language surprisingly well
have you read dating profiles that
explicitly mentions that your race is
not welcome I know that your place lacks
your stories have been similar dealing
with this particular form of play slag
which by the way can happen in New York
City and a Columbia involves a delicate
balance of maintaining some grace and
dignity educating yet not condescending
and simultaneously fulfilling some form
of cultural or gender expectation as a
queer chinese-american sis mail person I
know that this sort of play slag will be
lifelong and that my negotiation with it
has to happen both internally and
externally at Columbia I was glad to be
able to train as a peer advocate at the
gay health advocacy project I got to
learn not just more about sexual health
stigma and issues surrounding the lgbtq+
community but also about how to talk
about these issues with others at
Columbia I got better at dealing with
some of these abject forms of the play
slag but it is far from over
we the newly minted PhD graduates at
Columbia already enjoy a special vantage
point our education here challenges us
to understand many different forms of
plays lags indeed the physical the
academic and personal and beyond and we
are able to reach out to the people who
are newly feeling these
of lakhs in all corners of our
communities if today what I mentioned if
very few of the plays lags
i mentioned to you applied to you i
invite you to reflect on why you got to
experience so few of these place lags
and think about doing something about
these plays lags that you see other
people facing you to have the power to
do something to shrink some of these
lags do your class of 2019 we may very
well be able to tackle the physical
plays lags on our own by adjusting and
interacting with our new environments we
may very well be able to find a
supportive environment to overcome to
academic or professional play slacks we
will be encountering but to address this
last form of play slag i mentioned we
need all hands on deck this is no time
to be complacent
perhaps our time at columbia was about
gaining a set of tools not to fully
overcome all of the kinds of plays lags
that we can experience but to ascend to
that challenge
much like how a pilot had to learn the
new geographies of the skies we are
learning how to navigate our own place
lags with a dose of courage and the
strong ethic dear class of 2019 go and
soar high in these columbia blue skies
thank you and congratulations again to
the class of 2019
Thank You mr. Wong today's keynote
address will be offered by Professor
Rosalyn Morris Rosalyn Morris is
professor of anthropology at Columbia
she joined the faculty in 1994 and has
served as a director for the Institute
for Research on women and gender and as
a social director of the Institute for
comparative literature and society
professor Morris's work addresses two
broad sets of questions the first
concerns are histories political
economies and social lives including the
deaths and after lives of natural
resource extraction the second concerns
the force of the mass media and the
transformation is associated with
modernity
she has undertaken extensive at the
graphic fieldwork in southern Africa and
in Southeast Asia
professor Morris is the author of seven
books and more than seventy essays her
work has been recognized with awards and
fellowships from the Social Science
Research Council the American Academy in
Berlin the Institute for cultural
technology and media philosophy in
Weimar the stellenbosch Institute for
Advanced Study the Institute for
Advanced Study at Princeton and the
Rockefeller Center at Bellagio in
addition to her scholarly work professor
Morris is a filmmaker poet and Liber
test
professor Morris
[Applause]
Dean Alonzo executive vice president
Tolstoy assembled faculty students and
guests I'm deeply honored to have the
opportunity to address you today and I'm
especially pleased that I can join you
as you celebrate the receipt of your
doctoral degrees because this is also
the 25th anniversary of my own arrival
here as a member of the faculty then in
1994 as carlos's already mentioned I was
probably a lot like you a newly minted
PhD enormous ly hopeful a little afraid
and a lot uncertain about how to make
the transition from being a student to
being a professional most of you have
spent the better part of a decade in
pursuit of this degree reading
experimenting in labs and at the drawing
board doing research in libraries and
archives and in field sites around the
world your doctoral degree confers on
you recognition for what you know but
above all it recognizes the fact that
you have learned to learn and this skill
above all will you take with you into
the world where it will serve you no
matter what discoveries arise no matter
what fashions come and go for this you
can be both proud and grateful I join
you in thanking your parents your
siblings your friends your lovers your
spouse's your children for their support
throughout your time here and I also
want to recognize your teachers and your
colleagues including both your advocates
and your critics for as scholars we
depend on both and yes I speak of we
today opens a horizon in which the
community of Columbia's doctorates has
expanded to include you in its we we
welcome you today to a community that
includes both those who have gone before
and those who are yet to come
my hope for your future is that you will
be able to realize the in
enormous talents that brought you here
but I know that this is a difficult time
and even a dangerous moment in which to
enter what we sometimes refer to as the
real world and this is of course a false
distinction the university is in and of
the world and the world is in it it's
privileged place protected by the
institution of academic freedom and
sustained by the great knowledge and
wealth concentrated here nonetheless
derives from its critical function a
function that is always under threat
and that requires your collective
defense the question is how shall we
realize that function so as I
contemplated what I would say to do
today I could not help but recall the
following lines from a little novella by
Gertrude Stein I know it is just the
most dangerous moment in our history in
a kind of a way as dangerous more
dangerous than the Civil War daily we
are assailed by terrifying stories about
environmental destruction and
life-threatening climate change a
relentless pool of images from foreign
war zones and inner cities blighted by
racial hatred unfurls by the hour on our
screens some of you have been personally
wounded by these horrors and many of you
have devoted yourself to the pursuit of
remedies for these problems and we wish
you much success in that endeavor
indeed we depend upon it now the words I
just quoted about these dangerous times
were written by Stein in 1946
nonetheless the danger she saw then was
not unrelated to the danger that faces
us now to be sure Stein did not
anticipate the planetary threat Fuld
posed by fossil fuel consumption
deforestation and the use of plastics
what there are other points on which she
may offer us some insight first she was
concerned that it would be difficult for
people to learn how
to end a war and she was afraid that the
world to which her characters were
returning was one in which they would be
obsessed with jobs and unable to find
the means to satisfy their inner needs
the standardization of life worried her
as did production for its own sake
second she was concerned that something
was happening to language that it was
becoming formulaic and as a result its
capacity to express either the
consciousness of its speakers or the
truths of the world was at risk people
she wrote were all beginning to
articulate alike more than 70 years
later this country and much of the world
is still at war and if Stein reviled
Gallup polls for their yes/no answers to
complex questions we live in the era of
alternative facts internet trolling
hashtag politics and hate masquerading
as free speech in a time of click farms
and robo calls it is not easy to know
how to judge the speech that claims to
represent the interests or desires or
aspiration of those in our midst never
mind those who reside in more distant
places but you who have completed your
degrees by submitting and defending a
dissertation know as Catarina a
Brazilian woman said to the
anthropologist Schwab Ile you know that
thinking means caring for the words to
accept the mantle of the doctrine is to
accept the task of caring for the words
this is a strange kind of care we ask
you to perform for we ask you to do so
in the very moment that you subject
everything else to question and indeed
it is the unique and necessary task of
the university to protect this double
mandate of caring for the words because
they are our only vehicles for
truth-telling and critically
interrogating the received truths of our
respective disciplines
this task without which there can be
neither justice nor science calls us to
defend the university against all the
forces that would subordinate it to the
political or corporate interests of a
few it calls us to defend the only
instrument we have to forge relations
make peace and question ourselves but
what does it mean to care for words and
which words perhaps we can start with
leadership you have spent the last
several years in competition with
yourselves and each other as you have
tried to excel and prepare yourselves
for leadership in your respective fields
and this is as it should be and yet
today you sit next to each other as
recipients of the same degree an
equality of sorts perhaps you're sitting
next to someone you have never met
perhaps your parents or your spouse or
your friend is sitting next to someone
from a country they have never visited
who speaks languages they have never
heard regardless of whether you come
from upstate New York or South Asia East
Asia or West Africa you are here as a
member of Columbia's community and this
community holds you whether you are an
immigrant as am i or someone descended
of generations of Americans Native
voluntary or captive this community
holds you whether you are as mi the
first woman in a family to receive a
doctorate or even a college education or
whether your parents and grandparents
were scholars regardless of whether you
share the same political beliefs or
religious commitments whether or not you
inhabit the same understandings of
sexual identity or have a racial history
in common you sit next to each other
equal and alike in this accomplishment
what could it mean to lead here among
equals who are both like and unlike who
share an experience but
not along history we say we value
leadership but we rarely define it and
for lack of such definition leaders as
dine also remarked can sometimes lead
you where you do not want to go for lack
of such definition contemporary society
often measures leaders by the number of
their followers on social media let us
not go there well then what about
equality as we know equality is one of
the guiding concepts of this Republican
democracy and to my mind it is one of
the most important political concepts
ever adduced but as we also know this
same concept has been abused since the
beginning the history of civil rights
activism to which many people at this
university have devoted themselves over
the decades has been a history of
Labor's to realize this concept to
ensure that its constitutive exclusions
be overcome time and time again and such
struggles must indeed be undertaken time
and time again while rights are
protections enshrined in law they can be
revoked freedoms can be and are not
unfrequent infrequently withdrawn and
the realm of equality can contract to
become the mere privilege of those who
believe they are like each other and who
would exclude all others but if the word
is to be valued equality must obtain
between those who are unlike if it does
not it is mere resemblance this is why
we need to care for the word and by so
caring work for its realization for when
equality means equal access to
inequality when it is limited by
identity so that it obtains only among
those who resemble each other then it
has become an empty and indeed a
dangerously vacuous term limited in this
way it becomes the fertile soil in which
tyrannical leadership
grows at present people around the world
are agile ating powerful figures whose
paradigm for leadership also dominated
Stein's time dictatorial power vested in
individual men who led people where I
hope we would not want to go to go back
to that model of leadership with its
dreams of power and domination would
doom us all
you must find a better way you we must
find a better way
an alternative dominated neither by
celebrity followership nor based in the
idea that a right to rule rides resides
in the exception you do so in a moment
of utmost urgency when your decisions
must feel especially burdensome but to
the extent that these tasks are urgent
and burdensome they are also
opportunities to make a profound and
lasting difference we hope we have
prepared you well for this role but you
will also need to exercise your own
judgement as you enter not the real
world but other worlds these worlds are
conjoined but they are not one they are
internally differentiated and oftentimes
divided by structures that distribute
opportunity and especially education
unequally we at this great institution
are also part of those structures
beneficiaries even when we want to and
do oppose them a great and grave
responsibility comes with that status as
an anthropologist I spend a great deal
of my own research life in places
deprived of the most basic amenities
often without electricity sanitation or
sufficient food to end a day without
hunger my friends in these places many
of whom are undocumented migrants dream
of receiving an education if not for
themselves then for their children yes
in severe poverty they would
to receive an education they do not have
the means to claim it or treat it as a
right as a drian rich urged graduates of
Douglas College to do in 1977 sometimes
they granted a nearly magical status and
assumed as we sometimes do that a
certificate of education a diploma such
as you will soon receive will transform
their lives and grant them the
recognition that they longed for and are
otherwise denied on the one hand this
desire is entirely understandable and we
cannot wish it away on the other hand it
reflects the forces that Traverse both
their world and ours that can join them
in a structure of inequality so as I
conclude I want to persuade you that
what a gene-rich said to graduates half
a century ago remains the case to care
for the word education means not
reducing it to its certificate not
thinking of it only in terms of credit
hours or grades received returns on
investment or the value added dimension
of your resume that kind of thinking
would only reproduce the forces that
have been gathering since even before
Stein wrote her worried lament in 1946
but that have a new shape and urgency
today when I said that the university is
in the world and that the world is in
the university this is what I meant how
you think of your education here how you
choose to actualize its lessons will not
only reflect how you think of the world
but it will shape how you go about
changing it and that in turn will shape
this university to bear the
responsibility of Education we need to
enact the special freedoms that are
accorded a university like this one to
ensure not it's exceptional status as a
world apart but it's protected role in
enabling us to engage the world justly
and in pursuit of justice here and there
and in the relations between them
wherever they may be
welcome to this shared responsibility
which we inherit from the past and which
we owe to the future welcome and
congratulations dean Alonso executive
vice president Tolstoy assembled faculty
students and guests I thank you for this
privilege of speaking to you today
Thank You professor Morris I now have
the pleasure of introducing Miss Sarah
ARCA our a PhD candidate in the
Department of English and comparative
literature and the president of the Arts
and Sciences graduate Council who will
present the faculty mentoring awards is
our khabar today I have the distinct
privilege of representing all GSA s
students and recognizing two outstanding
professors the Arts and Sciences
graduate council a SGC instituted this
award in 2004 to commemorate excellence
and the mentoring of doctoral and
masters students the award is a student
initiative selections were made entirely
by graduate student representatives from
GSA s based on student nomination
letters across all disciplines
today we honor professor meredith gamer
assistant professor of art history and
archaeology and professor amy starr
Chesky director of the master's program
and oral history professor gamer
[Applause]
professor gamer this election committee
was very impressed by the nomination
letters received on your behalf
here are a few highlights meredith
approaches her students with quiet
confidence and deep-seated intellectual
curiosity she exemplifies the
pedagogical model that understands
learning as taking place with the right
combination of challenge and support
from graduate seminars to desert
dissertation defenses meredith
consistently holds us to the highest
standards of scholarly rigor while
giving us the tools to succeed i was
immediately captivated with art in the
british empire because of professor
gamera's meticulous curation of readings
and discussion topics and because of her
ability to deftly lead productive class
discussions observing her interact with
undergraduates as her TA constituted
perhaps the most effective lesson in
pedagogy i have received at columbia her
ability to be a great scholar and a
great person when whose patients care
and compassion are as boundless as they
are generously bestowed are rare as a
junior faculty member Meredith doesn't
have much time to spare but she makes
the time and in so doing makes the
graduate students in her MIT's confident
empowered and better equipped for the
challenges that lie beyond the ph.d
program on behalf of all graduate
students at Columbia University we want
to thank you for demonstrating
outstanding leadership of students
effective mentoring is not only the key
to a successful graduate program but its
benefits we'll pass on as a tradition of
quality mentoring practices throughout
the rest of your students
professor Starr Chesky the selection
committee was very impressed by the
nomination letters received on your
behalf
here are a few highlights dr. amy starr
Chesky is everything someone could hope
for in an academic mentor she encourages
her students to think about the oral
history practice not just as a series of
interviews but as real catalysts for
social change she encourages us as her
students to consider in greater depth
the social cultural and political
factors that shape how people interact
with their communities and by extension
with us as interviewers she has made
this past year of my life in the O HM a
cohort an incredibly rich meaningful and
transformative experience both in terms
of the things I've learned and made and
the beautiful and supportive learning
environment she's curated and created
she creates a classroom environment
where all opinions are welcomed mutual
respect is fostered participation is
valued
she's an engaging intelligent and open
instructor she gives feedback like I've
never seen before it's incredibly
thoughtful detailed and constructive I
truly don't know of anyone in another
master's program anywhere who speaks as
highly of their professors in the
academic environment they've created
Amy's a true gift to Oh hm a in this
university and I feel so lucky to be
learning from her on behalf of all
graduate students at Columbia University
we want to thank you for your
demonstrating outstanding mentorship of
students effective mentoring is not only
the key to a successful graduate program
but its benefits we'll pass on as a
tradition of quality mentoring practices
through your students
[Applause]
thank you Miss Erica Bauer and
congratulations to Professor a gamer
professors gamer and star Chesky we will
now recognize three PhD students with
the Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching these students were selected
from a large pool of nominations by a
committee that included both faculty and
graduate students the three students
selected to receive this year's
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching our Benjamin bhishan Department
of Chemistry Shula mid-shin our
Department of History and Catherine G
Department of Psychology
first mr. Bhushan mr. Bhushan over the
last two years you're teaching in the
Department of Chemistry has earned you
the highest praise from our faculty and
students you have gained a reputation as
a selfless teacher regularly going
beyond the call of duty to provide a
wonderful learning environment from
which hundreds of students have
benefited you have revolution
revolutionize how students experience a
traditionally demanding course and have
created a space in which a greater and
more diverse number of students can
succeed your students have universally
praised you as an inspiration citing
your passion for the material as well as
your enthusiasm and dedication as a
teacher it is with great respect
gratitude and pride that we recognize
your contributions and accomplishments
in the classroom and beyond with a 20-19
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching by a graduate student
[Applause]
miss Shin are as a historian of the
classical world you have shared with
your students your enthusiasm for the
subject matter and for finding relevance
and insight in ancient texts you have
inspired your students by helping them
make connections across cultures and
across time guiding and encouraging them
to experience the emotions presented in
the texts your students repeatedly
praised your ability to create an
intellectually stimulating yet welcoming
classroom environment they commend your
focus on inclusion all while you push
them to analyze more deeply and further
develop their critical reading skills
you represent the best of what a teacher
scholar can be intellectually rigorous
and accomplished generous with your
knowledge time and skills and committed
to thoughtfully conveying the insights
of research to the uninitiated it is
with great pride and admiration that we
join your students in thanking you and
recognizing you with a 20-19
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching by a graduate student
miss Z in your time at Columbia you have
combined outstanding doctoral research
with extraordinary teaching leading some
of the most challenging and important
courses for undergraduate and graduate
students in the Department of Psychology
your teaching excellence has served not
only as a model for your students and
your fellow graduate colleagues but also
as a model for other faculty who look to
you for guidance in designing more
creative assignments to finding clearer
expectations and fostering more
inclusive classrooms you possess an
exceptional ability to translate your
seemingly encyclopedia knowledge into
engaging lessons that communicate
complex content with varying levels of
complexity you scaffold students
learning inspiring them to actively
grapple with challenging material that
previously thought was beyond their
grasp your excellence in teaching
extends far beyond the classroom the
more than 30 research assistants and
honors students you have mentored can
attest to the pivotal influence you have
had on their development your passion
for research the rigor with which you
approach every task and your exemplary
work ethic inspire your students helping
them to develop their own curiosity and
pushing them to believe in their own
capabilities as scientists a brilliant
researcher an exemplary teacher and a
dedicated citizen to your department the
University and your field as a whole you
are a one of wonderful role model to our
students an addition to our profession
in addition to our profession
we are proud to recognize your
achievements with a 2019 Presidential
Award for teaching by a graduate student
[Applause]
congratulations to mr. Basant miss
shanaar and izzy on their achievements I
am now very pleased to present the dr.
devon T Wade mentorship and service
award this award recognizes a masters or
doctoral student who most exemplifies a
commitment to community building and
mentoring as demonstrated by the late
dr. Devon T Wade the award was
established in 2018 in honor of the life
and work of the 1t Wade when the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
conferred his doctoral degree
posthumously Wade had enrolled in the
doctoral program in sociology at
Columbia University in 2011 and came to
be recognized as one of the university's
most gifted doctoral students Wade's
dissertation research which focus on
stigma drama and discipline in the
school setting was recognized by
distinguished awards including the harry
s truman scholarship the ford foundation
pre-doctoral fellowship and the National
Science Foundation graduate research
fellowship Wade was passionate about
teaching and creating inclusive learning
environments and he was deeply devoted
devoted to building networks of support
and mentorship for students from groups
that historically have been
underrepresented in the Academy he was a
founding member of the Columbia
University graduate student of color
Alliance the purpose of the dr. Davonte
Wade mentorship and service award is to
recognize Columbia University graduate
students whose work reflects dr. reflect
dr. Wade exceptional commitment to
scholarship teaching mentorship and
service the selection committee is
pleased to have selected as the
inaugural winner of this award
mr. Joss T green
mr. green a committee selected you
because of your demonstrated and
consistent accomplishments in all of the
areas recognized by this award research
and scholarship teaching and mentoring
professional and community service and
community building like dr. Wade your
sociologist who studies prisons and the
effect of incarceration on broad
communities as a scholar activist who
studies incarcerated trans women of
color you you work alongside and
together with members of affected
communities and their advocates to
create more just systems of
incarceration and reentry
in society according to your peers who
nominated you you are and I quote a
tremendous teacher and mentor for
undergraduate and graduate students
alike with your seminar race gender
sexuality and punishments receiving high
praise from your students
congratulations mr. green and to all the
nominees for the inaugural dr. devon
co-ed mentorship and service award for
your extraordinary work we applaud you
[Applause]
we now arrive at the central point of
the ceremony the presentation of the
doctoral candidates we ask you to come
forth as we call your name in
recognition of your individual
accomplishments professor richard so sir
shake the social dean of academic and
student affairs will read the names of
the PhD candidates as the approach and
cross the stage
receiving the doctoral degree in
anthropology one Missouri Hegel's
Fernando Montero Myrtle Jones receiving
the doctoral degree in applied
mathematics Roshan Sharma on urban Sina
highway Jai UN Jay Dao receiving the
doctoral degree in Applied Physics and
Applied Mathematics Jeffrey Taylor
jyothirmayi Mundell receiving the
doctoral degree in architecture Meredith
Gallego receiving the doctoral degree in
art history and archaeology Alex
Weintraub arethey menuing Leia Pires
arena Tolstoy
Lorenzo fig OT
Michaela della Casa Connie
Choi receiving the doctoral degree in
astronomy Gemma Wolcott Green Andrew
Emmerich receiving the doctoral degree
in in biological sciences way Wang
receiving the doctoral degree in
cellular molecular and biomedical
studies Z au feu he way Cheung Fong
yuxuan Wu Yin glue Shang Rossi soon Chen
Chen
Yauch yung Chen Vitelli for men Jinyoung
Jo receiving the doctoral degree in
biomedical engineering
mirela Alto e ji-sun Park
Davina Chu hey Yong Jie joshing Lau
receiving the doctoral degree in
biomedical informatics Joseph Romano
Alexander yayi receiving the doctoral
degree in biostatistics paying Wu Chi
Yong goo poo Xin cho Chung Hong Qi will
Diane young Annie Lee receiving the
doctoral degree in business min Chen
Sheng yuan Zi Oh Ashley Carter Alice Lee
donna cannes y on yo amid bitch sorry
Noah Costello rachel mang Francisco
Castro
[Music]
Fei Long yaar eat Evan
she loo who he receiving the doctoral
degree in cellular physiology in
biophysics Michael Holsey Jonathan Kim
Megan
Belcher doof Renee Stephanie Sigmund
Margot Brandt Nathan Jones Daniela
Georgieva receiving the doctoral degree
in biological sciences haengju dong
receiving the doctoral degree in
genetics and development yin yang
chemical engineering Nicholas Brady Jack
Davis Connor Bilchik Brian Tackett when
je fais
Elaine Gomez voila
Abdullah receiving the doctoral degree
in chemistry
Evan Dowd Anastacio Vova dan Eva
Risa navette Bailey
receiving the doctoral degree in
chemical physics James she receiving the
doctoral degree in chemistry
Andrew show receipt jin-joo zhang
receiving the doctoral degree in civil
engineering and engineering mechanics
apostolos serous Andrea Poulos Katzen
Santos
sangguk young receiving the doctoral
degree in civil engineering and
engineering mechanics lay Shao Kahn Wang
Daniel bartilson
[Music]
gregory james Fitch receiving the
doctoral degree in classical studies
evan jewel Joe Shepard receiving the
doctoral degree in communication Charles
Barret dyani chitra Tom glacier Bear Zhu
by Curt receiving the doctoral degree in
computer science
Richard Townsend Timothy son
Sara Leviton pritam Duta Chara a must be
Nora Farah gang hope receiving the
doctoral degree in earth and
environmental engineering
Matthew beta Mei Chang chuan Joe Terran
Ambani
Jing Bao yeah leo
l'amour Dan subrata does
yep
receiving the doctoral degree in
computer science Andreea low torini
marios Romina's matthias liquor yay
receiving the doctoral degree in earth
and environmental sciences buting zhang
zhengzhou tan Inga whoo
Colin Raymond
Laura Haynes Juan Carlos de Bezos Kira
Olson
Daniel Rasmussen Caroline Leland
Francisca Landis Elizabeth Schoenfeld
Rajab regime receiving the doctoral
degree in East Asian languages and
cultures dan Xin Zhao Jun Wang Chi
Cheung Jeffery Tyler Walker
Allison Bernard Lele receiving the
doctoral degree in ecology evolution and
environmental biology Benjamin Clark
receiving the doctoral degree in
economics
Christopher cotton Jeremy Ward Oscar
Surya
thumb walk on on a rug Singh son Chong
Li Wei Jay John Matthew Teachout
christopher Gibson Jing Zhang Jia Ming
Zhu Jian hoon
Dejan yen Xiao chuan Lee Jung Joo jo bhi
sach not Samora
Rajinder Singh moon receiving the
doctoral degree in electrical
engineering as if Achmed Sun ghoul taken
Nathaniel Ching Lin Naggar race Karima
yawn ghazzal fizzle Neil Alexander
gozman David kidney Chen XI
jingchou John Sean a nan Xiang Liang
Chen ou yen today a goon Deeja receiving
the doctoral degree in English and
comparative literature
Benjamin bearish Alex
Fabricio Victoria Wyatt
atif a Akbari Alexander Paulson lash
Sara arc power receiving the doctoral
degree in epidemiology Patrick Dawson
Eleanor Hayes Larson anton Palma
Mandy shamone Goldberg
Beth Rubenstein David Fink receiving the
doctoral degree in rope Fran in France
and romance philology rose Gardner Sarah
Lazar Adam a zap receiving the doctoral
degree in genetics and development
Margaret Kirkland Maria stoop Niko's
Michael swell Lander receiving the
doctoral degree in history Hannah
Elmer Ethan Yi Susana Ferguson Rachael
Newman Tanya boot Acharya Shula meet
shanaar Nicolas Mulder
Daniel Boone our Kressel AJ Murphy
Arthur Surratt a
Haroun Kulina receiving the doctoral
degree in Italian Alyssia pelant e
Giuliana visco Allison DeWitt receiving
the doctoral degree in Latin American
and Iberian cultures Daniel de Silva
Daniela worst receiving the doctoral
degree in mathematics Elena
Georgie when John choy Lee Shi Zhang
pack Hindley Chi Xiao ma
shall we tan wen hua you Mitchell
receiving the doctoral degree in
mechanical engineering
Andreea Westervelt Braden Zappala Jenny
Rd Leon Christopher DiMarco how Han
Zhang Cheng Zhi yuan Jun young Timothy
Olsen receiving the doctoral degree in
microbiology immunology and infection
Michelle me wrong
Mariana host inna mi de Lila Yosef
Philippe shet scoffs key receiving the
doctoral degree in music Beatriz Gobert
mark Hannaford Ralph white Paula Harper
receiving the doctoral degree in
neurobiology and behavior Nina
so layer Jenkins receiving the doctoral
degree in nutritional and metabolic
biology Brian Jose Gonzalez Steven
shekel kathryn choe Cheung Yee Zhu
receiving the doctoral degree in nursing
Illume tark
receiving the doctoral degree in
industrial engineering and operations
research Octavia
Ruiz Luca deli receiving the doctoral
degree in industrial engineering and
operations research
Francois Fagan knee MA
nor hon suka
Mario Escobar Santoro shall pay
chung-yong you Wang Ming Xin Jiang Xiu
son Fei he g-pen Lu receiving the
doctoral degree in pharmacology and
molecular signaling jose kiha de Namira
guess you're not scope so I'm sorry
receiving the doctoral degree in
philosophy Namira
gasps Jonas Cobb or hane Lily Hamlin
receiving the doctoral degree in physics
Jung Han Victor Ginty
Heather McCarrick Andre Petroski Stefan
countrymen receiving the doctoral degree
in political science
Colby Hansen Lindsey Dolan Alicia
Cooperman Jacob Copas Jasper Cooper S
Lee Han sig Gilly
Nicholas Lotito summer Lindsey
Aaron Zambia Joseph Sutherland Camilla
vegara
receiving the doctoral degree in
psychology
Kate turetsky jocelyn show receiving the
doctoral degree in religion
Elizabeth Tinsley receiving the doctoral
degree in Slavic Languages Robin
Jenson Holly Meyers receiving the
doctoral degree in social work
Philip Marotta nan Jiang receiving the
doctoral degree in sociology
Christina chauka eller Nicole Valdes
Sarah Sachs receiving the doctoral
degree in socio medical sciences Rana
Popkin Stephanie Grillo
AG o ma KO la xu a when Wong doctoral
degree in statistics morgana
Oster Jean whoo-ha chef Joseph Edward
Chang receiving the doctoral degree in
sustainable development Timothy four men
[Music]
me de pinna Tia under law see Alice Tian
Bo Jane
Denise Dukey
Jason Chun you Wang receiving the
doctoral degree in theater Rosa
Schneider receiving the doctoral degree
in urban planning Lauren Fisher Maiko
Nishi Yun Jing Li Lin Ying ha Astrid
Renata La Silla Smith
receiving the doctoral degree in applied
behavior analysis Liana Mellon receiving
the doctoral degree in applied
behavioral by analysis Brittany Bulai
lara Gentilly me Sarah
Suseela sung & eun-jung
Angela Chen receiving the doctoral
degree in Applied Psychology measurement
and analysis shall Yong Zhao you by
receiving the doctoral degree in
behavioral nutrition catherine white
adele lee receiving the doctoral degree
in clinical psychology
Lauren shuttle receiving the doctoral
degree in cognitive studies in education
Mariana Lam Nina she min ki ji leo
pinata
Sagada Hernandez receiving the doctoral
degree in counseling psychology Kishida
Bowen white receiving the doctoral
degree in economics in education Sidra
Raymond receiving the doctoral degree in
English education mink Jung Choi
receiving the doctoral degree in
mathematics education
sun-young bon eva Dabrowski receiving
the doctoral degree in philosophy in
education Jessica Davis receiving the
doctoral degree in social organizational
psychology danielle pfaff receiving the
psychology Arielle Bernstein receiving
the doctoral degree in speech and
language pathology Aquila Raja receiving
the doctoral degree in measurement and
evaluation head yeah Ahmed Aang
and now my parting remarks to the
graduating class during your stay in
this institution we have we have
endeavored to train you how to think
write and speak like members of an
academic field as a participant in the
intellectual community defined by the
mores and conventions of your discipline
living in the process little room for
time for more for much else indeed
looking back at the foundational myths
of the modern University one can detect
readily a desire to place the
institution in a location of exception
with respect to the social as an
enterprise that derives its force and
reason for being from its insularity
from its distance from societal concerns
this is part and parcel of the
apprenticeship model of graduate
education and explains to a large degree
the sense of loneliness that we have all
felt at one time or another while in
graduate school as if we all have to
recreate for ourselves and within
ourselves the principle tenets of our
chosen discipline and thus engage in a
project of intellectual self fashioning
that necessarily had to keep the world
at bay given the efforts that you have
expended in achieving this goal it would
be justified in thinking that the
triumphs that you celebrate today surely
should be enough and yet the Spanish
philosopher Jose Ortega y Gasset wrote
in his meditations on Don Quixote in
1914 just as the world was about to
embark in a cataclysmic war an aphorism
that comes to mind to describe what I'm
hoping to convey to you as you leave
this institution Joe Sojo
i'ma circumstance here is in all a
salwar area no me salvo yo which can be
loosely translated as I am myself and my
circumstance and if I do not redeem it
I cannot redeem
myself there has never been a more
connected more transnational
infrastructure linking us
instantaneously to other individuals
than the one that has been built by the
technological scaffolding of our digital
world but paradoxically we have also
never been farther away than we are now
from experiencing a sense for the
Commons farther from the belief that we
have some responsibility to our brethren
and from the principle that what is best
is what is good for the largest number
of people arguments that rely on the
assumption of the common good as a given
appear to have lost their power of
persuasion because what was once a given
can no longer be assumed to have
collective purchase and assent it has
taken us a long time to arrive at the
melancholy realization that just because
we can communicate with countless
unknown individuals
we're not by that very fact creating a
community the university may have been
created to keep the world at bay outside
its walls but we should not allow that
mythological foundation to determine our
relationship with our surroundings the
very distilled concentration the
monomaniacal attention to your
intellectual projects that has allowed
you to be where you are today
he's a decided strength but a colossal
lead imperceptibly to a withdrawal from
the world that is not that different in
its effect from outright
neglect struggling against the insular
experience in which you had to immerse
yourself to be successful in graduate
school will perhaps be the most taxing
the most demanding task you will
undertake in the next chapter of your
life that begins today nonetheless
everything that you have learned at
Columbia will only acquire its full
significance when you're able to
articulate its meaning for the Commons
in spite of the requisite headlong
plunge into our disciplinary Millia that
has characterized your time as a
graduate student you we must never lose
sight of the larger social context that
will endow our work with its ultimate
significance
we are Atlas as a society at peril of
losing that sense of responsibility for
the common good
without which our work will be
diminished but more important without
which no understanding or application of
justice may sustain itself your studies
have endowed you with powerful
analytical tools and equally effective
powers of persuasion and you should know
you should use them to protect the
health of the social compact to
strengthen the resilience of our common
bonds strive to be happy as an
individual but always keep in mind or
take as an admonition that if you do not
have if you do not also endeavour to
redeem your circumstance your own
personal fulfillment will be in jeopardy
never lose sight of the fact that many
many persons even absolute strangers
have contributed sometimes invisibly to
this very personal success of yours that
we celebrate today and that the best way
to acknowledge a death is through your
renewed commitment to the essential
business of being human among and
alongside other human beings we arrived
then at the end of this magnificent
ceremony go forth and be our
representatives and emissaries to the
world and all of us at Columbia will
rejoice in your inevitable achievements
make us and your relatives and friends
prouder still about you than we are
today
will the candidates please stand so that
we may give them a final round of
applause
[Applause]
you're all invited to champagne
reception immediately following the
ceremony at Ansel Plaza under the tent
I asked friends and families to wait to
exit until after the faculty and
candidates have ascended the steps to
our campus
[Music]
family and friends on the east side of
the lawn again we ask that you please
wait for the graduates to exit before
exiting the seating area those on the
west side of the lawn we ask that you
please exit promptly
they prepare for our next ceremony
please join us on Entel Plaza for our
reception thank you for coming
[Music]